In civil cases where money is at stake.
There is extensive discovery by the parties.
In other words,
in a civil case,
each side we'll give the other side the name of all the witnesses that know
anything about the issue in dispute.
The parties will even be able to take depositions.
That is,
they'll be able to sit down with the witnesses one at a time and ask them
questions and the witnesses will answer the questions.
The court reporter will take it down a,
there'll be able to see any documents that are going to be introduced that have
any relevance to the case.
They'll inspect,
uh,
maybe the scene of where the incident was,
whatever it may be.
But basically by the time the trial starts,
uh,
everyone will know everything about the facts of the case and the question will
just be presenting those facts and having the jury decided criminal cases where
life and liberty at stake quite different.
Uh,
in many jurisdictions in the country,
in many places,
it's trial by ambush.
Uh,
the defense really doesn't know who a lot of the witnesses are until they take
the witness stand and testify against them.
Uh,
the criminal rules generally prescribed that.
And again,
this is generalizing over 50 states and the federal government.
So there are differences in each place,
but generally the prosecution must give the defense lawyer,
uh,
any statements made by his or her client.
Uh,
any documents or tangible evidence that might be a in the possession of the
prosecution that might be used,
uh,
that,
that can be seen,
uh,
any mental or physical examinations,
which are taking place,
uh,
the defendant's prior record and other words,
the rap sheet,
uh,
and a summary of any testimony of expert witnesses.
Uh,
but that's the minimal,
that's about all that some jurisdictions,
uh,
provide.
Uh,
so as I said,
often it may not know if a witness what a witness is going to say until that
person takes the witness stand or even who the witnesses are or what the
background of the witnesses are.
Well,
the Supreme Court has held that at least in some instances,
uh,
particularly when there's evidence that tends to show the defendant did not do
it,
or at least can be arguably,
uh,
are used in an argument for innocence,
that the prosecution does have some responsibility to disclose evidence.
Um,
the Supreme Court held in,
uh,
1963,
that the prosecution is required to disclose any evidence that's favorable to
the accused.
This was in the state called in a case called Brady versus Maryland.
And that cases often just used as a,
a term now for the disclosure of evidence,
Brady evidence,
uh,
as people will call it.
But we're talking about exculpatory evidence.
Uh,
not long after Brady was decided,
uh,
the court decided in another case called Miller versus paid.
In that case,
the prosecution had argued throughout the trial that the stains on some
undershorts that had been recovered from the defendant,
uh,
were blood when in fact the prosecutor knew all along they were paint.
Uh,
and that there were not.
So the Supreme Court reversed that case and made clear,
uh,
that in that kind of situation,
that evidence has to be disclosed to the defense.
Uh,
the court has also said that a prosecution cannot knowingly presents a false
testimony,
uh,
during the prosecution's case in a case called an to pool versus Illinois and
decided in 1959,
uh,
the prosecutors should witness the witness testifying for the prosecution,
said he got nothing in exchange for his testimony,
no reward,
no incentives whatsoever.
In fact,
uh,
the prosecutor had promised to seek a reduction in his sentence.
So,
uh,
the supreme court said,
you can't do that if you make promises.
If the prosecution makes promises to a witness,
uh,
then the prosecution has to disclose that to the defense and that can be used to
argue the credibility of that witness a and Gago versus United States.
And I decided in 1972,
a one prosecutor had a promise to witness that he would not be prosecuted if he
testified.
Uh,
but then there was another prosecutor who didn't know anything about that
particularly bargain that had been reached.
A,
and when the witness testified,
he said there had been no promises made to him.
Again,
the Supreme Court said,
uh,
the entire prosecution office has to be responsible for knowledge,
of what,
uh,
deals have been made,
and reversed that case as well.
These are the easy cases.
These are not cases that are going to be hard to decide.
Uh,
but we will see that this becomes much more complicated,
uh,
as the cases become more involved.
Or is there more factual disputes in the cases as a question of whether the
evidence just tends to,
uh,
raise some question about the strength of the prosecution's case or,
or whether it's actually exculpatory.
Uh,
so,
uh,
and of course the other part of this that I should mention is the question of
whether or not the defense ever becomes aware of it.
Undoubtedly,
there are many cases where there's evidence such as what I'm going to talk about
in the graves case and John Thompson's case,
uh,
which never comes to light.
Uh,
and therefore there is no issue,
uh,
but where the evidence is discovered serendipitously,
someone calls the defense lawyer and tells them about evidence.
Often there's a freedom of information act or open records act litigation that
produces evidence that the defense did not know at the time of trial.
And if that's the case,
then there may be litigation about whether or not,
uh,
a case has to be set aside.
A will cause the failure to disclose exculpatory evidence to supreme court.
Uh,
in later cases though,
uh,
cut back quite a bit on what's required in terms of disclosure.
Uh,
first of all,
the court said,
uh,
there,
it was no violation,
at least in the case of augurous versus United States.
This was a failure to disclose the criminal record,
uh,
of a witness.
Uh,
one of the things the court looked at in deciding that case was the fact that
there'd never been a request,
uh,
made,
by,
uh,
the defense force for that record.
Uh,
and the court said this did not violate Brady versus Maryland.
This was not a violation of due process,
which is the part of the constitution,
the due process clause of the 14th amendment,
uh,
that the,
that states are required to provide this information or the fifth amendment in,
in federal cases.
Uh,
the court said the prosecutor may not have known the evidence was exculpatory or
may not have known that the defendant wanted it also,
uh,
there's no violation if the evidence is not material.
Uh,
that was what the court said in a case called the United States versus Bagley.
there,
even though the defense requested that any deals and promises that had been made
and the prosecution had not disclosed,
uh,
witnesses had been paid money for the testimony they gave.
Uh,
the court refused to reverse the case,
uh,
and said it was not material.
Uh,
that evidence is material only.
If there's a reasonable probability that had the evidence been disclosed to the
defense,
the result of the proceeding would have been different.
This is really a harmless error standard.
Uh,
basically the court is saying this is evidence that,
uh,
even if it had been disclosed to the defense,
it would not have had an impact on the outcome.
Of course,
the argument is that appellate judges who didn't see the witnesses,
who didn't sit in the jury box,
who don't know how the jury has assessed the case,
may not be able to really know whether or not had this evidence been presented
to the jury.
Uh,
it would have affected the outcome.
or not.
Um,
Anthony Graves case provides,
uh,
an example of how close these questions can be sometimes a,
the key witness,
uh,
against Anthony Graves who was synced to death in Texas was a fellow named
Robert Earl Carter.
And he had told the prosecutors during some private meetings with them to things
that were important.
One,
uh,
that graves had nothing to do with the crime.
Uh,
and second,
that Carter's wife cookie,
uh,
was her name was involved in the crime with him.
Uh,
of course,
that trial,
he testified that graves participated in the crime and didn't make any mention
of cookie participating,
uh,
in the trial.
Uh,
the court found that,
uh,
the prosecutor did not disclose this information even though graves counsel had
requested it.
In fact,
the prosecutor had deliberately misled,
uh,
the defense counsel with regard to these statements that had made.
And in addition to that,
the prosecutor called a Texas Ranger,
uh,
Kaufman,
who testified that Carter had never said anything different.
Now,
obviously,
uh,
the prosecutor knew,
that this statement,
uh,
that Ranger Kaufman,
made,
uh,
was not true.
He knew that it was false.
Uh,
and as a result,
uh,
the United States Court of Appeals,
vacated graves conviction,
his case was sent back.
Uh,
and it's interesting to look at the history of the case before it made its way
to the United States Court of Appeals for the fifth circuit.
Grades had first tried to raise this and the Texas Court of criminal appeals.
Uh,
but unfortunately I had a very bad lawyer with very little experience,
uh,
who,
didn't raise the issue.
And then when they tried to raise it a second time,
the court held that it was barred,
that it was procedurally barred because it hadn't been raised the first time.
Uh,
then when it gets to federal court,
the Magistrate Judge who first examines the case and then the district judge who
examined the case,
uh,
conclude,
that there was not a substantial probability,
uh,
that the,
outcome would've been different.
Uh,
had the case gone.
had the evidence been disclosed.
Um,
the United States Court of Appeals for the fifth circuit says first of all that
the provisions of the antiterrorism and effective death penalty act did not
apply.
Uh,
in this case,
this is a,
as we've talked about in other segments,
uh,
greatly restricts the power of the federal court to issue a writ of Habeas
Corpus.
In a case like this,
uh,
the court also found there was cause,
for the procedural to fault that were some issue is not presented because was
there a reason for that?
Uh,
and the court said there was in this case because the state did not disclose the
evidence and little after the case had already gone through,
at least disclose some of the evidence until the case had already gone through
the entire,
uh,
state,
appellate process and was actually in federal court when the evidence came to
light.
So graves can hardly be faulted for not having raised the issue in state court
when he didn't even know what the prosecution knew at the time.
The case goes back for retrial.
But the new,
uh,
prosecutor,
brings in a very experienced,
uh,
Harris County that's Houston assistant district attorney who had tried a Kelly
Siegler.
Uh,
she'd sent 19 men to death row in her career as a prosecutor,
uh,
in Houston.
Uh,
she called the prosecution of Anthony Graves at his first trial,
a nightmare and a travesty.
Uh,
she said it's a prosecutor's duty,
uh,
never to fabricate evidence or to manipulate witness or take advantage,
of victims.
And she said all of these things happened in this case.
Uh,
so,
uh,
here's a case in which a man was prosecuted,
sends to death,
denied any relief in the Texas courts,
partly because he had a very bad lawyer,
uh,
for his,
post conviction review of the case.
Uh,
but then when's the case in the United States Court of Appeals?
And when it goes back and independent prosecutors brought into assess,
it finds that there's this kind of prosecutorial misconduct,
uh,
that happened in the case.
Anthony Graves has been free ever since.
Uh,
he talks to people around the country about his experience.
what happens,
you can learn more about Anthony Graves by going to his website.
Anthony believes,
uh,
dot com,
one other case that illustrates both the question of disclosure,
uh,
as well as accountability,
is a case of a man in Louisiana.
John Thompson,
uh,
John Thompson was accused of separate crimes,
the arm robbery that happened one time and a murderer.
These crimes are separated by about two weeks,
and they happen in New Orleans in 1985.
Uh,
in the arm robbery case,
the police had taken a swatch of fabric that was stained with blood of the
perpetrator.
These for some kids who got robbed.
And in the process of it,
there was a scuffle and there was blood on the pants and the police took a
sample of that.
This is of course the kind of critical evidence that law enforcement uses to
solve crimes.
Uh,
they sent it to the crime laboratory,
uh,
and it came back that it was blood type B.
Uh,
well,
uh,
there's no mention of the results of the blood tests at trial.
Uh,
in fact,
two days before trial,
uh,
that one of the prosecutors,
gave the crime laboratory report to another prosecutor.
Now that prosecutor later denied it.
This is the report that said what the blood type,
uh,
was.
Uh,
before trial,
the prosecutors checked all of the evidence out of the property room of the
police department,
except for that Swatch of fabric that had the blood on it.
Uh,
Thompson goes to trial.
This is in the arm robbery case.
He's convicted.
That's then used against him.
It,
his capital case.
So that he doesn't take the witness stand.
Uh,
he's convicted,
he sends to death and tea and spends 18 years in custody,
uh,
14 of those years,
on on death row,
uh,
one of the prosecutors,
Jerry Degan,
uh,
learning that he had cancer and that he had a little time to live a admitted in
1994 to another that he had suppressed the blood evidence and John Thompson's
case.
But that of the prosecutor never disclosed that to the defense or for that
matter to anyone else.
Uh,
John Thompson was scheduled to die on May the 20th,
1999 and he almost did.
Uh,
what happened was that an investigator,
uh,
started looking,
leaving no stone unturned,
looking one last time,
uh,
and went to the crime laboratory and discovered the blood report that had been
there all along that said,
the perpetrator had blood type B could have been John Thompson.
John Thompson's blood type was o.
And so once you have the blood report,
a Thomson could not have committed the crime.
Uh,
and in fact,
the arm robbery charges against John Thompson are dismissed.
The Louisiana Supreme Court then reversed the murder conviction,
uh,
saying that because it was tainted by this earlier,
a conviction,
uh,
Thompson was entitled to a new trial and that the new trial,
John Thompson testified a number of other people that knew about this incident
and testified as it turned out,
and in all probability,
the person who had accused Thompson of the crime was probably the person who
committed it.
He came closer to fitting the description.
Then Thompson did,
uh,
at any rate,
it took the jury just about a half an hour to acquit,
uh,
John Thompson.
So after 18 years in the custody of the state of Louisiana,
14 on death row,
John Thompson walks out a free man after he's acquitted,
but he does more than that.
Thompson sued the district attorney,
Harry Connick,
Sr and others,
uh,
saying that misconduct by the prosecutor's office,
basically the failure to disclose this blood report had cost him 18 years of his
life in a,
nearly resulted in his execution.
Uh,
prosecutors have complete immunity for what they do as prosecutors.
So he couldn't directly sue the prosecutors who tried his case or a Harry
Connick senior,
uh,
the main prosecutor,
but he did sue Harry Connick and other people on a theory that there were so
many of these violations.
So many times when prosecutors in New Orleans had failed a turnover evidence,
there'd been four cases reversed,
uh,
before John Thompson's,
for the same reason,
uh,
that he had failed to train as lawyers,
so that they would be sure to find and turn this evidence over is they're
required to do by the constitution of the United States.
A jury in New Orleans awarded John Thompson $14 million plus $1 million in
attorney's fees,
but that was soon to be taken away from him,
uh,
by the Supreme Court of the United States and conduct versus Thompson.
A conic won at trial court of appeals split evenly on the case.
Uh,
but the Supreme Court granted,
uh,
review,
and said that there was not enough reason for conic to require that his
prosecutors be trained.
Uh,
this is not like the court said,
sending police officers out with weapons without training them on the
constitutional limitations on the use of deadly force.
Uh,
which police departments do.
The Supreme Court said that there was no reason to think,
uh,
the,
the deputy district attorneys,
uh,
would need special training after all.
They had been to law school.
Uh,
they are responsible as lawyers to continue their education,
uh,
after law school,
and they learn on the job from other prosecutors.
Uh,
of course,
that was one of the problems that Thompson was raising that perhaps,
uh,
learning from other prosecutors in the Orleans parish district attorney's
office,
uh,
was not really teaching the right lessons.
That is that this kind of evidence has to be disclosed,
uh,
as opposed to suppressed.
Um,
justice Ginsburg descendant,
she was joined by justices,
Briar Sotomayor and Kagan.
Uh,
so this was a very close case.
John Thompson lost the $15 million by a five to four vote of the Supreme Court.
Uh,
justice Ginsburg and heard a sense said from top down,
uh,
the prosecutors did not understand their obligations.
They hid all kinds of exculpatory evidence,
not just the blood tests,
but all kinds of evidence from Thompson,
uh,
which he had requested over two decades.
And it almost resulted,
uh,
in his,
execution.
And another segment,
we'll talk to John Thompson,
uh,
about his experiences,
the trials he had,
the time he spent on death row,
uh,
and his effort to hold the prosecutors accountable,
by filing this civil suit,
winning it initially,
but then losing at the Supreme Court.